elle est née le 28 décembre 1975 sur
antenne 2 il ya 45 ans
stade 2 l'une des émissions les plus
emblématiques de la télé plus de quatre
décennies d'exploits sportifs d'imprévus
et de moments cultes et vive le sport
ferrand tendence à 2 c'est le rendez
vous dominical pour tous les fans de
sport à la présentation des premiers
numéros
robert chapatte ou roger couderc à leurs
côtés des journalistes comme thierry
roland léon zitrone ou encore pierre
salviac pris d'un fou rire en 1978 au
moment de parler de cheval vous m'aviez
dit vous étiez passionné par le csi de
dinard semaine d'ailleurs dans certaines
de mes jours commente jean-marc ayrault
si je peux continuer à jouer malgré
trois cavaliers avaient effectivement
dès lors plus tenir compte aussi
hilarant autres moments cultes de
l'émission avec thierry roland
en 1982 le psg vient de gagner la coupe
de france de football
francis borelli le président du club
décide de faire une surprise aux
journalistes sportifs est-ce qu'il est
convenable de dire publiquement que
j'aimerais faire un cadeau à thierry
roland lui qui a toujours été très
gentil et très avec mon club ce qui est
autorisé
[Rires]
les présentateurs s'enchaînent gérard
holtz en 1985 puis patrick chêne en 1992
c'est lui qui reçoit le 7 d'or pour la
meilleure émission sportive en 1995 sur
la scène
l'équipe de stade 2 et survoltée on a
festa de dimanche on a joué au foot hier
soir on a fêté le 7 d'or ce soir et
demain un jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même ambiance sportive avec l'équipe de
france de handball en 2008 les experts
viennent de remporter le titre olympique
sur le plateau les joueurs sont
déchaînés portrait maintenant lui de
celui qui a marqué deux c'est lui qui
t'a 2 est diffusé sur france 3 depuis
l'émission fait partie des plus
anciennes encore en activité
[Musique]